my name is Ben cornea I've been in the
u.s. Coast Guard for 15 years my job in
the Coast Guard I'm a rescue swimmer
every couple of months we deployed a
grid in Ottawa for two weeks at a time
we have the occasional medevac but
that's about all I've gotten down there
we were nearing the end of hurricane
season when Hurricane McCain started to
move in we received an emergency signal
at the manoosh with the crew of 12 was
going down I think we were all a little
bit nervous conditions were not ideal
but this is what we all signed up for
the crew that responded to the emergency
call were myself as the rescue swimmer
lieutenant McCarthy the AC flew in the
left seat lieutenant post did most of
the flying that night
petty officer Andrews operated the hoist
we took off in the 60 headed to the
last-known position when we arrived on
the scene all the lights on the ship
were still lit up as we got closer we
realized the ship was sideways in the
water and getting pounded by large waves
we were thinking this is the big one
that we always trained for
as I was lowered into the water I was
surprised by how windy it was once I
reached the water it was warmer than I
thought there were large 12-foot swells
and surface winds of 60 miles an hour or
so hours okay
once I located the raft I went over to
the door and a crew member unzipped the
door because of the high winds and the
size of the swells it took a lot longer
survivor halfway up altitude Comics
welder alright sure I'm going to need to
whenever I ask you to bump it I'm gonna
need you to bump downward motion okay
bump bump bump or bump bump bump bump
bump bump the original plan was to get
all 12 survivors so we had plenty of
room in the helicopter with eight
survivors safely in the cabin we
realized we would soon run out of fuel
and our only choice was to head back to
base we were on the ground for about 45
minutes before we were airborne again
after arriving on scene and conducting
the first choice flight mech realized
the cable was fraying
we were forced to return back to base we
switched aircraft returned to scene
storm conditions had grown worse but we
were able to pick up the last three
survivors at night he rescued 12 people